[Applause]
get down on living student transition
hundred that's a confident looking good
range shot season tickets for the next
season and chasing a four out of five
which means the really special thing
about this place is the people are fans
fans and by elite athletes with special
plays she trying to get free well
defended here's Iguodala pulling up and
connecting with 2.4 remaining on a long
to Sager I knew it was it allowed down
to five shot clock stopped eighteen
three to get cold
[Music]
[Applause]
a six-point lead in the end of a wild
first quarter and andre iguodala drop it
in the triple the other day that he's
still angry he was only second team All
Defense last year has Toronto finishes
off the gorgeous delivery from Iguodala
if this unit on the floor for the
Warriors will beat you is pushing it in
transition unselfish players egg without
with the beautiful drop-off pass behind
the back and direct role does the rest
Wiggins looking for a runway lost it
Iguodala flashing forward McKinney a
very patient waiting for that
[Music]
[Applause]
the double championships in Connecticut
[Applause]
he sees the contact feels the contact
clay there through all that attention
Megan Dallas spikes it with the right
hand
they're looking for their largest lead
heading to halftime
miss Alexander deflected by draymond
they're still running the floor so you
get down low again on the handle
Durant three neither they're getting out
rebound play it beautiful defense on
Wallace get it down you've got the
bandage here down right down the lane
was not going to get the way of that
maybe that will inspire them that was a
terrific play Andre Iguodala feeling
bouncy tonight
gonna come right into your living room
and dump right over your sofa grant good
defense again he's actually grabbed by
Harold if the corners were happy wasn't
called because they'll get a dunk and a
foul I'd love to play a little bit here
once in a while it's break and they
didn't call it and I liked it then play
it on through let the players decide
what's going on to the crossover gets it
into Looney shot clock at three Iguodala
open his three is good I can show you
that better than the free throws half
the time
Vijay on Iguodala back some down laundry
swiped it here comes to rant running
with frit his play here's a way for
three got it
well the steal by Iguodala he runs
through to open up space for clay and
they did it perfectly miss Brooke for
eight seasons turnover by the thunders
second turnover here in the quarter now
they get dolla to the rim gets the layup
on Adams and the lead is back to nine
for the Thunder good passing that time
by the Warriors agra tala
with the throwdown
[Applause]
in change
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
six minutes remaining in this third book
Thanks pants for big we're gonna set it
up for Thompson there he is again
Siobhan Lodi extra pass Iguodala with
the slab timeout Milwaukee sometimes
he's the guy making the pass some time
he's the guy make him a dunk at thee and
it gets late early in these young guys
career he's already headed as there's a
god of Duncan he's always ready headed
to where they're gonna have to make a
decision
who's the missus big addala pushing back
to Durant
either senator schatz arts days but her
them to come to double knock it away
hurry the pushing him he can top on
transition
[Applause]
you get to steal double-teaming but
watch what happens here
Iguodala gets a nice screen to bring
back room to make the most of it you get
it
well show you something as only is some
can't do it like guys again downer
ditches foot knocked away picked up by
Iguodala
Iguodala drives gets inside
[Applause]
we clearly got it off in time and the
whistle and Iguodala will shoot one
free-throw this has been throughout
tonight
[Applause]
a dollar to the basket with the lineup
on the floor we saw the previous jump
shot in the corner miss bus put his head
down
he talked about the three emergence of
draymond Green
he made that pass there now Iguodala
wall on two gets the left
great point out for eternity pensive
intensive guys in our game but he can do
it one bet he can do you one better he
can not only get a steal but he can go
school no I want to try Vince all backed
away and Livingston ahead Iguodala goes
by Porter and why is the other way is
out there for going to sit all except
cousins I've a match
[Applause]
I have the pinpoint pence per satyr on
skis watch Durant - fire
[Applause]
that's why everything six assists a game
they could do even more Cory Joseph
tripled off his heel lady Laker bench an
excellent job here in the first half Ali
up three the Iguodala greens limping as
he comes up the floor where you land on
a foot yep like there's Rondo's right
foot curry fakes all rifles up a
stopping point nine remaining plays on
the offensive end Steph Curry taking the
double-team finding a wide open are
getting a dolla all by himself for the
beautiful finish warriors up by five at
the half
[Music]
Rondo pass deflected by Iguodala
million-dollar drives goes inside the
hollow he throws it down
his main guy's gamble by Rondo and a
Throwdown biiig wa taala a 35 year old
Iguodala
[Applause]
the turn
I am grateful past 13 of 18 shot clock
is off final seven seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to block the shot warriors running
[Applause]
feels out granted the crossover
but a two-possession game in the ball
and that's deflected dream on saved it
play cutting play fading
Thursday's game against Sacramento a man
whose wife had their second child
congratulations on the baby inside pass
[Applause]
now with the finish over his former
teammate Kenneth Faried the contact and
the hoop those two playing together in
Denver absolutely
Terry trying to get free curry inside
the time calls risky mates
responsibility to communicate and let
him know him Iguodala clearly got that
off in time we don't play well
particularly sometimes this cook gets it
inside there gaddama two on the shot
clock
Iguodala nails it a credit the Pacers
need it from the Warriors defense these
are very tough shots
[Applause]
those are the doing that and they give
it a lot of this road trip little good
shot was fantastic here in the third
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Porter the Warriors 3435 snaps it on the
way
[Applause]
but there's Iguodala just snatching that
ball out of midair and riding it right
down up to the basket and Batum blocked
the loonie dunk hoppers gotta finish
that shot
he's gotta finish things up any guys but
he ain't he's got to go a little reverse
on that other one because he have clear
opening so here he goes this is the play
and you're going to get a three-point
play possibility really hasn't been part
of the story here tonight because Kevin
Durant is happiness way and it's not
just on Patrick Beverley screen goes all
the way in transition misses with the
left look at that pass by Kevin Durant
Haidee all starts the defense look at
egg with da la with the turnover off the
in bounces don't execution and that was
a play call and train line the heart is
sold with his team he doesn't strip at
college career and a good start with
Philadelphia they like them there but
have a chance to get device Harris a
trade that worked well for both teams
curry gets inside a nice feed from big
evallo to michael green with four fouls
on Durant
Iguodala throws it down the red sea park
Andre deciding to get Iggy with it it's
a big time finish bottom veteran and
it's back up to 19 this is playoff
career is for Durant at 45 in Game five
Iguodala curry back to Iguodala
get under five minutes remaining a 16
point warrior lead draymond Green
throws it off but it gets out where is
gonna stick with that hi double drag
screening roads getting Nene in the
action against Curt carry the pass to
green throws it up the playoffs Thompson
[Applause]
gets this warrior team you need another
guy that can score the rock then you got
to respect their am boy they're getting
wide open looks and the monk up and
layups and dunks but Durant drives it
harden comes to help
they're shooting clock at five play
Thompson fakes take it down another
corner three Aska hook Andre Iguodala
does it again and it's a one-point game
[Applause]
Iguodala defended by Shumpert
free buzzer-beating
triple by Iguodala time for the Golden
State Warriors often time in town in
time for tea Shaun Livingston his first
minutes mrs. - and a dollar right there
on the follow on another offensive
putback for Golden State just got to do
a better job
I'm staying with them hi thank you Lisa
[Music]
Harden's fat ass [ __ ] dolla knocked it
away Paul got hit in the eye Livingston
drives left-handed backs it home it's a
tie game will egged on foul Willard's
almost stolen
[Applause]
way more join the year with the first
tee ball defense because when it matters
most
this guy has food with the beat and
elite all-time defendant great hands the
strip seals the victory outstanding
defense by Andre Iguodala
take a difference look they're saying to
get up on them they try and knock it
away from curry curry frozen Livingston
acid back back Adama think Adela puts it
up let's go andre igudala drills it with
5.9 remaining panels defense got to be
better Steph Curry cannot have his whale
on the offensive end
[Applause]
but succeed from draymond Green
flowery catch mega dollars throws it out
of bounds
wide open jumper for Lowry doesn't quit
on a place sends it out loony with eight
to shoot gets it to the paint goes right
at siakam gets his own rebound back out
egged Allah the God Allah drives down
egg with dalan green I don't care if
they drive it like this shoot the three
Thompson floats it in green floats it up
because Tyler throws it down hook finds
cousins he finds Iguodala
shot clock winding yes to put it up
notices the clock winding down and
desperation three and comes up big
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content